last month marks the 20th anniversary of
your debut album which is great remember
when you came out and I was like Molly I
was like I was like our generation is
like big bold vocalist because we grew
up with so many great vocalists like
listen and The Ballad era my god the 90s
were so good
but I was so excited like can you can
you believe it though 20 years
I definitely look back at old pictures
and now that it's the 20th anniversary
and I'm just like oh oh you like it baby
Christina but now I feel like I could
like mother her now I'm like it's okay
like we're gonna you know at me because
when you get older you're just so much
more self-assured and it's like yeah I
wouldn't pay to go back to money if it
gets me Matt that oh my way but I could
do without a lot of the insecurities
that you shot and whatnot when you get
older but yeah and also like everybody
thinks it's success success like oh you
must be the happiest person ever and
like most of those were darkest moments
cuz you're so busy and you're you're
just so damn people think you're like
the greatest there and it's like I'm so
tired and I mean yeah and your voice is
wrecked the people expect and you don't
learn how to say no you gotta learn how
to say no and you're like no you have
the right to say no and that is
something that you know they don't teach
you especially as young girls coming up
in the business - it's a very
male-dominated industry and I always had
older managers and things and agendas
and a schedule like since I was 7 it's
hard to look at my kids and be like I
love it I couldn't I was born to do it I
can't think of anything else but yeah I
mean people they look at how it looks on
TV and all the glamour and things like
that but the inner workings and the
behind-the-scenes of it all it's it's
brutal you have you do have to have
exerting to have a thick skin learn to
say no like you said and and be there
for yourself and surround yourself with
people that love you and don't want to
just ride your coattails and make money
off it's true and it's
I've always been a diary girl so I don't
know about you but like I'm a scrapbook
or a diary girl so I like I literally
but it's no it's so interesting I was
looking back at old Diaries and I was
like oh my god some of me has like not
changed at all like it's I think it's
really important to stay grounded and
have that connection with yourself and
who you are we're not forgetting where
you can we have real backgrounds and
histories yeah we weren't raised with
Silver's no no offense to anyone that
had opened for you know green like my
other kids are gonna be like that that's
what's so funny my kids are gonna never
know what it's like get without like you
know so can I must be a little my son is
sometimes like your house is too big I'm
like oh my house is I got mad at my kids
because I was like Ernie my god ain't
your mansion got a woman's shape but
another thing I love about you that's
coming out and I'm very excited for this
is you have a huge Halloween project
that you're part of right I do tell us
I'm a tremendous fan of The Addams
Family and it's coming out with an
animated film so I am so there I haven't
seen it yet so I'm very excited and I'm
singing one of the title songs off of it
called haunted heart and it's really
cool and and I love Halloween to like
it's right up there with Christmas I
love dressing up the kids
I literally have walked through haunted
houses that I do like I don't do that
for the neighborhood house I literally I
was through bringing children out of the
way I was like I don't like
I married the wrong person he loves to
scare the crap out of everyone and I'm
like if you do it there's no cuddles for
you for a week I hate being scared
I can't kind of you haunted houses no
they're like you can pick your level
though you can go like okay I want I
want and maybe win I like it creepy like
scary Candyland we're onto something I
kind of love it I think you came in with
a great way I know you're gonna do this
um but also here's the big news also as
well you're Vegas residency at Planet
Hollywood was just extended what do you
love cuz everybody's doing a Vegas - so
what do you love about it the experience
you have to come bring a fun group of
people because I love feeding off the
energy but it's it's it's a great it's a
great environment it's a great place to
be expressive and creative and you know
I feel at home most when I'm on stage
and it's a five sensory experience so
you can smell taste it's like you can
get on the ride that what is it yeah
yeah actually it's so funny you say at
least we're I know I also have a
snowplough idea I want to do a Christmas
show in Vegas I want it all to be a snow
globe great my whole world so we're
still some oh my god you should come and
we should sing a song in Vegas okay
[Applause]
you can have any crazy cuz it's being my
husband I tried to because we have four
kids and it's like fun to just be an
adult like a fun adult again and have
like a night with your ladies or your
friends wherever and so do you have any
wild fun nights and Vegas all the good
ones I'm I'm proud to have minimal
memory abut I like to go out with my
like crew like my dancers are so fun to
go out with my gosh or not you're not
your big sister like yeah you look great
no I'm not gonna join you no I kind of
like let them under but they're
entertaining they're just like my bands
like that yeah my pants like that
they're all cool I just want to thank
you I know you're so busy or a momma
you're working hard I get it already
it's all good I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this